foreign again one of the top goaltenders
in the NHL last season across the way the
man has been a real tough one for
the Rangers samion varlamov in goal
signing their goaltenders edius Sorokin and
samyang paralamo to long-term deals [Music]
and there is first round draft pick in 2021
printed off ninja it keeps uh keeps growing
up getting a little older getting a little bit
more mature getting a little closer and these
games Butch as you well know boy for these
young kids that are close and trying to make
a run trying to get a roster spot these games
are extremely important it is you can have a
bad game or a bad shift I mean there's a lot of
pressure on this oh right there how about that
[Applause]
[Applause] [Music] [Applause]
[Applause] 22 year old former second round
draft pick [Applause] back to the pump
Hollowell Cinder who is celebrating his 25th
birthday for the Rangers he wears number 81.
shot by Lindgren to save off the glove and
the rebound score Tyler penlight in his first
Holmen the Rangers with their aggressive board
checking and I want lots of as they just drive
towards Annette to win the one-on-one battle and
then they left all alone in front there's a shot
from the point Joe and then you're right
I'm in a High glove over a barley and then
it's two nothing this game hasn't even started
Harley sometimes as a coach he gets so focused
in on you know the game itself and you're not
paying attention to really what you want to do
yeah playing Lambert as you mentioned Butch in
his second year but I go back when you coached
well your first year as a head coach did you
just trying to get to know the guys kind of
have that same approach on the bench you just
want to kind of watch everything as opposed to
getting right in the middle of the coaching side
well my first goal is with the Boston Bruins and
we play an exhibition game against the Flyers so
I never really saw the game Joy was busy juggling
lines because there were so many fights there's
Criner scores Oh What A Move by crash Kreider
[Applause] [Music] team that's always been so good
defensively the last number of years and
they have been tourists to start this one
good play there stepping up and knocking
the puck out to the neutral zone [Music]
bashing number 20 is on Mayfield moves it across
on shot points they score on
the rebound that's the four
didn't waste any time and it was a tough angle
got a fortuitous bounce off the floor again good
Puck movement here by the armors is what I like
no hesitation at all but he's open get the shots
at the net and then coming right in and we talk
about goal scorers they don't stand out there
in a way they move themselves toward the puck
and just enough of a of an opening and then I
go on the other way then two big guys are having
a little conversation with bush you're smiling I
look at those two guys I think back to my years I
go I love those kind of guys I protected my butt
John you were down there what'd you see yeah I
saw and well what I will tell you is it was a
rather calm conversation but pointed I know
Ross Johnson made a reference to referee's
age and I think Matt was basically saying if
this is going to continue then you're going
to have to answer to me [Applause] three
on two across Hopkins leading the rush
[Applause]
offensive player and as he's gotten a little
bit of a couple of good punches by around K
there and good good good big fight and then uh
you know what they talked about it so it's fair
that rampy is sixth round draft pick of the
Rangers in 2020. play 53 games with Hartford
and the American League last season shot went
wide no loss of Manpower on the ice five minutes
each for fighting we're nearly five minutes in
the second period Rangers leading three to one
and it's set up for wheelers scores like
wheeler he just dumps it in Wheeler will
end up with it here tries to get it to Austin
which he does and then as the play is broken
up that little spinorama pass turns out
to be a Beauty look at that thing they
put snitching with that pass for the hour he's
been remarkably consistent and he has uh such
a such a good feel with his with his partner
they communicate a little jealous hit the post
stare up the ice a little bit of the mindset for
Peter laviolet when he has this kind of belief
a good coaching staff that Peter
laviolent has put together Phil
Housley Hall of Fame defenseman and a head
coach of the National Hockey League was an
assistant to Peter laviolent in Nashville and
a great addition on this supreme construction
set how happy do you think you know you want
them to take responsibility for the results
well there's a good rivalry oh boy friendly
rivalry between India Sorokin and Igor Schuster
and who are good friends the best way from The
Ring the best of friends and but they compete hard
and they're they're both great goaltenders put
in front by wheeler just straight by Brzezinski
'll probably see if it's broken next game
settled in after a fast start to that shot put
in by durando capes look at that was good quick
passing and you know get it to the middle of the
ice and just throw it across and beautiful play
by case and you know the key right there stopping
further than that how many guys Joe do you see go
by the net they don't they don't stop and if he
doesn't stop there he doesn't if he keeps going
he doesn't score but durando who played well for
the Islanders last year with a with a couple of
opportunities great skater we worked hard one
more game one more goal by the Islanders and uh
we'll give them an opportunity to
make a little bit more interesting
went off Karen's glove that he's able to get a
little help and cover up and stop playing here
and then he'll get his own rebound absolutely
I mean he'd watch him turn in for text to Puck
leans into his left and got his head up all the
way and looks to go I'm not sure if he was going
High glove or look at him he's taking a little
look and he just doesn't get it up high enough
connection Thursday night here at the Garden
against the devils and pandanico will join us
with us into the glass [Applause] you know Kenny
he's pretty intense yes he is he's really changed
he's just not old enough yet to
be able to relax tornado sending
it to the empty then it won't get there
with time winding down 10 seconds to go
good job Butch thanks yeah thank you guys
it was always fun great having you here but